very very important to invite people
that you disagree with so it was you I
thought it was a troll account I thought
it was a troll account
if you had gone into the page you would
have known I'm so disappointed in your
sister okay one minute I have my reasons
he's advising the youngsters in the
wrong way when the people are not
married the youngsters they're thinking
about this guy I want to be like this
guy I want to treat my wife as a slave
we have to put him down he's a cancer to
the woman no he's a danger he does he
does have followers I've never come
across a secure man who gets female
attention who gets money who gets the
things that are maybe make you a high
value Man start speaking down on a woman
like she's a piece or something on the
floor there is no secure man that does
this
at the same time I think my question is
is why do people get so triggered why do
you value him so much what is it no no
nothing is I didn't come I was invited
to come and comfort him and I refuse I
think a lot of modern day women in my
opinion especially Western women with
the women here white women my people
they they they don't understand the
value of being in the kitchen I know
that sounds it's very I know it's a very
harsh as a white woman I actually agree
with that because a lot of these cardi
B's on the world and all of these girls
that we watch and listen to and we look
up to they have an agenda to break us as
women yeah so that our men can't tell us
what to do when's the last time our
wife's helped out with our work let's
start a petition we're going to call
ourselves the blue pill guys why are our
wives not helping us anymore
trying to make a point here we do not
ever complain about it everyone's
talking about toxic masculinity and no
one talks about the toxic the toxic
masculinity in a woman no one talks
about the toxic masculinity that we
women are developing
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
the most merciful the most trust or
praise His glory and gratitude belong to
him before we start I want to do some
disclaimers so uh our last episode which
was pertaining to this very topic kicked
off
um for a variety of reasons uh people
were angry they were upset I just want
to make a disclaimer as uh the host and
someone that contributes to these
discussions is that I don't invite
people here who I disagree with I want
to make this very categorically clear
yeah if I brought everyone who I agree
with if I said guys does everyone like
apple and everyone said yeah we love
Apple we love Apple there'll be no
discussion there'll be just everybody
loves Apple yeah so the point I'm saying
is that I might invite somebody who is a
maybe a toxic feminist who beats her
husband up no problem it's what you're
doing is wrong but I would like for you
to come here so I can challenge your
views understand you better and maybe
change your mind about certain things so
um that's one disclaimer secondly there
are people who um are making some claims
and I want to uh touch upon that as well
which is we are free mixing meaning that
um the sisters and our honorable Sisters
by the way and our brothers have come
here to intermingle this is a slander I
ask you to feel Allah
um if you do not know your religion
please study your religion yeah and the
sisters who come here are honorable
sisters which is one of Brothers is his
wife our dear sister is here to have our
contributions as well so I ask you to
fear Allah in your accusations and
slander the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said the one who guarantees
what's between his lips and what's
between his legs I will grant him
Paradise do not make comments if you
speak behind us thus backbiting if what
you're saying about it is not true is
slander our sisters come here for the
sake of Allah and the brothers who come
here for the sake of Allah we come here
so we can benefit you guys at home one
of the biggest Fitness of our ummah
today is divorce people are getting
divorced Left Right Center sister soul
deals with sisters I speak to brothers
and I don't know you guys experience but
the point is the reason I started the
show is not for fame and Views and money
whatever it may be yeah it is genuine
inshallah for the sake of Allah of how
we can combat these things that the
family units are going through we
already have the LGBT to and all these
other madnesses attacking our family
unit on top of that we have divorces
since that uh disclaimer's out the way
this is going to be a part two of our
episode that we had which was very
controversial there were things that
were set and that some people got upset
about obviously he was challenged as
well which was brother Matty I'm going
to open the discussion the discussion
was basically should men cook and clean
um so when I see this brothers and
sisters I know there is some people said
for example like Shaquille said on the
last one uh by the way I need to give an
explanation to that um Shaquille not
that by the way I'm not vilifying
brother Matty we don't want to follow
brother Matthew under the bus there were
certain things I didn't know about him
myself but Shakir had no he didn't it's
the first time you met him yeah so which
is my fault because I didn't know that
you regret it or not but the point was
that you was not aware yeah so that's
inshallah you can touch up on it more
the discussion at hand is the following
should men cook and clean
uh it looks like I'm going to start with
maybe
yeah
probably Builder I'm a security officer
and today we're going to answer this
question about men cooking cleaning what
is a man's job looking after his family
looking after his family like looking
after his kids and his wife so if he's
if his wife needs help with cooking and
cleaning it should help out 100 that's
his support in his family and the thing
is she's not your slave you know I mean
or anything else she's your spouse you
help out with your family you know I
mean you support them so the thing is if
my wife needs help she's not well or
she's busy with the kids because she's
been looking after the kids 100 without
doubt I'll help her out that's a man's
job looking after your family it's not
like providing for them and protecting
them is looking after your family that's
like that's what my my dad taught me to
look after your family you know what I
mean so if my wife needs help 100
without doubt I should help it doesn't
make you a weak man or anything like
that it's nothing to do with that you're
there to support your family you know
that's it okay interesting points yeah
but
um there's certain things I want to make
a bit clearer I have a wife my wife is
actually the co-producer of the show by
the way all the topics and discussions I
have we have a little debates at home we
discussion we do this topic Etc yeah
she's actually out there's two cables
that was missing and I haven't eaten all
this she's going to get me some food
mail I'm bless her yeah
um she will be here inshallah very soon
um I agree look I understand but in
today's time we're not dealing with
you you probably have an amazing wife
may Allah blessed to preserve your
marriage here but we are dealing with
search and sisters who are having
certain demands you have to cook you
have to clean when you come so just to
make it understand we're not seeing
generally it's a no-brainer actually he
said the last episode is this even a
discussion point the reason we're
discussing this is because we are having
for example two extremes
when there's a red pill for example oh
cooking cleaning for example you're
going to tell me to do that you're gonna
you're gonna pay the rent Etc
which brother Matthew was saying which
we've told him very categorically clear
another extreme is the toxic feminists
who are coming and saying no you have to
cook and clean yeah and the discussion
here is the following and I think
there's nothing to be pondering upon has
men ever come to their wives and said
why do you not ever help me with my work
the reason I mentioning this is because
it's never a talking point you will
never see Brothers you come and say to
their wife I've come home from work can
you help me with my work why did you not
never tell me can you imagine we start
moving and we go why are these why why
are the sisters not helping the husbands
in their world right this whole our
sisters will come and say well she's
also doing some work and we'll say yes
but the discussion point is what and
tell me if I'm wrong why is it that oh
why doesn't he do the hoovering why does
he not do this why is there a discussion
point where I don't need to be told to
help my wife I'm trying to say
I'm not sure I found Telly um agreement
okay please tell us why don't because
that's the reason
as well absolutely
um I think like we are
um
starting the conversation on the wrong
point we are like doing tick for tack
when actually this is the massive issue
even the way like people have understood
the topic is not about I am doing this
so you are doing that if I if I was to
think like that because men's a provider
I have to do this and I have to my job
is 24 hours you will never compare your
work
like the work of mothers and wives what
they do at home and I do I do not like
the fact that because you are providing
I've got to do all those things no
subhanallah and you're not even
providing like our fathers used to do
they were hard working physical work you
are sitting most of the time in front of
a screen so please let's just put this
as well because the way you're talking
to me or something not generally
speaking no we are out of three years
Corona everyone was home working behind
screens but they were like the brother
last time was describing like 40 I'm
working it's like he's sweating he's
doing something crazy we most likely
doing more physical work than most men's
maybe today I'm talking screen people I
am not denying what you're saying of
course like for me the first role of the
man is not cleaning it's not cooking
that's not his job and I know that Jesus
has to take some accountability because
they expect it they have this mentality
feminism or what whatever that yes the
husband has to know he doesn't have to
he does it out of compassion
do not have to cook or clean but I do it
because it makes sense it brings balance
to the couple and I do it with happiness
I am happy I'm proud to be able to serve
a husband there is no like ego attitude
that today womens are trying to like
feel like oh yes no it's submissive no
it's not it's it's a it's
discussion between husband and wife
should be done like the thing is if my
wife goes she's working and stuff can
you do certain amount of the house and
I'll do certain amount of hours there
shouldn't be no arguments or nothing
like that then if I'm working certain
amount of hours and she's working as
well you meet but the thing is my thing
is I work I made that decision to work
to look after my family and my wife's
decision was to look after the house and
look after the kids but that's decision
we made together it's not just your
decision this is how we should be yeah
should protect the wife and the men has
to be the provider it's not just you
making that choice as a husband and may
Allah bless you because alhamdulillah I
think it helps the marriage like
stability as well it's something that
Allah courageous to do he has encouraged
the men to provide for the for the wife
for the family and for the wife because
naturally it's her nature to take care
of the home because she's generous by
nature but the the issue I have today we
are talking about societies where the
woman has to work as well as the man but
there is no 50 50 at home she is
contributing to the bills she is
contributing to the providing side of
that she shouldn't no she shouldn't
that's why no no I'm saying like but
everyone everyone's situation is
different it's a crisis it's difficult
okay sorry sometimes sometimes you said
about when
um for example
um the men are asked to cook and clean
and things like that and do things at
home but there are certain circumstances
that I've seen before in husbands and
wives where the husbands have asked the
women to contribute or held it over them
that they aren't contributing for
example towards paying so yeah it does
work in both ways but for us we hunt a
lot we we make it work because we do a
bit of both like I do I work but my main
priority is to stay and look after my
children and my husband and I need to
know basically like I do expect my
husband to cook and clean he's a human
being every it's the life skill you have
to do that but I do expect him to do
that if I'm not there then surcharge is
looking after my children and I know
they're well looked after they're third
you know and everything so I do feel
like bottom line yes a man should you
know cook and clean
and one thing just disclaimer because
we're dealing with trolls um our dear
sister is um she's on the way of wearing
hijab because I'm like oh but she's not
fear Allah yeah and the sister she's oh
yeah because you know oh but don't know
please shut up yeah okay this is the
ancestor Amira they were having to go at
her oh but your hair's showing she
doesn't even wear the hijab sister Amira
by the way yeah she's trying to and the
way she was getting attacked just that
because in people's Journeys okay just
to give them I'm so sorry
your job is not forced or no that's a
person you know it's my wife's Choice
she doesn't have to wear it for me she
has to wear it for uh Allah you know so
that's it that's it the thing is I know
you maybe you might force your women to
wear it but they're wearing it because
of your fear no but love fear and that's
the one thing that we need to understand
another thing I want to say especially
with the river sisters don't do that to
them because so many sisters are pushed
away from Islam because of this reason
and think about bringing someone into
Islam in is such a rewarding thing think
about pushing someone away from Islam
what big sin is that you know and you
know a lot of people don't realize that
they think you call someone
yeah what about if you you're the reason
why someone left Islam or if you're the
reason why a sister who's trying to wear
the hijab takes you off fully yeah for
whatever reason please be just in
shalinda just come back to the topic as
well on that because modesty you know
it's something that I'm quite passionate
about yeah that this sister like hijab
doesn't Define my level of faith it
doesn't mean that I'm more poisonous she
might be more prized than me and sister
Amira was defined for maybe her hijab
not being perfect when actually
alhamdulillah she may have more
qualities than all of us she doesn't
wear hijab that was she was wearing
hijabi yeah but coming back to the topic
uh just come back to the top of those
few things mentioned here what's this
that
um forgive me the name sister bro sister
Ryan
yeah she said some points which is
important but the point is here that for
example sister soul said oh I'm doing a
um 24 hour well hold on a second because
the thing is now what's happening is
that what the men are doing is being
belittled what that means is oh like and
this discussion causes it's not deleted
let me let me tell you what okay let me
let okay tell me why this is free yeah
if we open these people said that does
this decide it is like oh it's okay
she's cleaning no no no no no no all day
no no like a woman's job starts at the
minute she gets up in just the minute
she goes to bed 100 but sister what's
this the point is this yeah as far as I
know as far as I know yeah men
if they come home if a man comes home
and goes what did you do to me that's a
very strange person like if a person
comes and says what did you do that's
strange no that's very wrong however I
don't hear this it might be wrong but I
don't hear the discussion of men coming
and saying this but rather the reason
why I had this topic in the first place
is because there's a phenomena among
sisters who are feminists are not
families not everyone's feminist they
are saying oh but when you come home
from work
um cook or for example this no why
should I have to cook I'm being very
honest look if I want to if I come home
can I see my wife is exhausted do you
think I'm an animal to be like oh no but
I'm an alpha male red pill yes you I'm
gonna beat you up now no I'm gonna say
you're exhausted no problem dishes not
to do dishes we are you need to have
mercy on my way of believing men
nobody's saying that the point is though
you do not not some people do not see
what the men do I'm so sorry he puts his
life at the line you do security yeah
bro people get stabbed to death yeah
biggest stuff today please so so the
thing is here is that when men are doing
work it's kind of like just because we
don't visually see it for example the
kids the kids see what mom is doing
running around me Allah blessing they
have so much Mercy but they don't see
Dad lifting up those bricks
to the kids your father others working
hard don't make noises coming home to
rest okay yeah
I'm the first one to praise
alhamdulillah and you know what I will
never remember you saying this on
another podcast and I know you do may
Allah bless you I know you I remember
these exact words you said that you do
that but we're talking about those who
don't who when the husband comes home
um yeah but you should do this and that
you don't do this enough for me but you
don't see the men doing it but um I've
seen loads of situations that a lot of
women bring their man down because they
work and stuff and they're not giving
the woman that what she needs and
they're trying to like that's exactly
what I was going to say so they make him
look like oh you don't do nothing
outside so come on yeah do that I feel
like their marriage yeah it has got they
they obviously feel underappreciated to
be digging their husband out
with those situations that's what I feel
like they obviously I enjoy taking care
of you I enjoy cooking I enjoy cleaning
making our home lovely because I enjoy
that and it's appreciated and respected
just as your hard work outside the house
and the thing is one thing I want to say
that I don't want my wife doing things
for me that she has to do things for me
I wanted to do things to me before me
because I wanted I wanted to do it
because she said I wanna I wanna look
after you I want to do the same for her
that's the difference that a lot a lot
of relationships a lot of marriages out
there because the ma the woman has to
look after the husband the man has to
work so the thing is this is where the
problem is yeah is having that respect
and love for each other you know what I
mean and the thing is the like my wife
says to my kids than that your dad is
working hard don't wake him up or this
that so this they know and we still wake
you up yeah
sister SWAT sister Ira um
Michael we're going to come to you guys
about sister SWAT
um
tell us a bit like for example what's
your take on the matter when it comes to
cooking and cleaning because we like
well I came across your content uh
watching I don't know what they're
called Just Produce something like that
and very bizarreling I've actually done
a video
um asking you to apply to the bitter
truth and you already have she basically
she already got in contact with the team
yeah uh and us and my wife may Allah
blessings managing this as well you
already applied and she was like yeah I
already applied because okay I didn't
know so sister's wife you did mention
some points in that podcast when it came
to for example
uh when he was previously married but
you would prioritize and and this is
where if I'm not mistaken you was also
working yeah please tell us a bit more
about that please so um
so yeah so there was I think I've so
I've always worked ever since I was 16
and when I got married at 29 I was still
working then had the baby
um but I can honestly say maternity
leave and then alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah in a certain way we had
covered straight after so my daughter
was at home with us those two years were
the best years of my life because I got
to see both sides I remember your video
yeah so I got to see both sides I got to
see the independent you know working
woman who was almost I wouldn't even say
almost I was a feminist you know I was
very for girls do your thing get your
own money we don't need a man sort of
kind of mentality and then getting
married having my baby it Allah put this
Rahman in my heart you know
alhamdulillah and slowly but surely I
started to see the hard work that he was
doing and even though I'm working from
home and I've still got the child he was
still working and me looking after her
and seeing her first words and him
coming home to a nice clean house with
food and then you know ask somebody's we
love our Auntie you know the fragrance
putting that on and just having that
that lovely evening it just it made my
heart swell and I started to do a lot a
little bit more research into like
traditional female and male roles and
that's when I started to see that
it's I'm not seeing all of this around
me in fact the traditional female role
is pushed down and it's sort of
ridiculed and people look down on it and
they're like oh you know you're he's
taking you know he's he's taking
advantage of you it's and and that's not
really the case because where I'm going
to work I'm putting my hard work into
this company some fat cat at the top of
the company's getting all the benefit
but when I'm at home I'm seeing the
benefit in my husband and my children
and my home
and to me as you describe the happiness
particularly you know my maternity leave
where I actually even have to focus on
work and he would go to work his stomach
is full he's coming home you know if
he's in a bad mood I can see that I'm
not trying to jump on him because you
know men for us females we like to talk
and kind of connect whereas for them
they want to disconnect and deal with it
because who do they have to talk to they
can't moan to their friends they can't
moan to their family they can't moan to
their wives because we don't always make
ourselves emotion available even to
accept them their stress yes the
difficulties we've like I had enough
already your kids and then yeah yeah
and your kids made my life yeah
and I joined you when you said because
it's only when I was hard working and
very stressed that I understood like
what it takes Hannah for a man I want to
come home I want to have some meal yeah
I want to have calm I want to have like
you know what a smiling partner the
recipe is so simple if you think about
it like you guys would agree yeah one
lie about home
wife with a smiley face greeting you
that's it nice food yeah and just sit
next to me I'll mentioned this another
thing I go yeah I just like the presence
of my wife there and then the families
were like is she a pet is she a pet what
what a joke but my ex-husband was like
that as well sometimes you're okay to
sit next to him and he wouldn't like we
don't need to talk it's just but that's
something to happen sisters man needs to
as well help and she put the wife so
when she comes when they come they let
she's less tired she's available she's
prioritizing the men but for that
sometimes she needs a bit of support and
say you know what let's cook let's put
the dinner the kids to bed and we can
have some time together okay so I just
finish your point there's you want to
ask a question yeah uh
one just hold it just one second are you
finished um no I was just gonna say so I
think the answer to the question is and
when it's put in the terms should as in
is it an obligation is it a duty no I
don't think it's a Duty or an obligation
on the man to help clean and cook and do
everything and I'm talking about the man
who's providing protecting and the the
actual man that you know Allah once
bought us I don't think it should be a
Duty or obligation or he should but with
dealing with each other with empathy
with love and you see that your wife is
tired if he's that good man he is going
to want to help you exactly yeah he's
going to want to he should be able to
but he shouldn't have to thank you thank
you that's that's essentially the point
that I mean yeah
we've got a question this is a New
Concept we're doing by the way we have
some people who are listening
um Dominic the camera's gonna it's not
gonna go to you yeah so um these are
these are our guests who are listening
um so sister Tara
yeah okay yes this trailer so
um can we have the camera no you're not
gonna okay it's the wide angle she won't
be in it
you won't be an assistant sit down okay
okay you want to ask a question for the
audience
in answering that question
um
they're just doing it because they feel
like you're that Mom at home mom you
know is
I've always got seen as something
important
so it's a purely a personal choice but
they want to leave
I want to go watch
a man's income enough and she has to
what so she's stepping in to support him
in his room so in that scenario the
question would be absolutely different
so I think there's that he does help
because
she's stepping in to support him in
Israel but but I would say there's two
answers to that yeah oh she's Tuesday so
she's choosing to work out of her own
auction then in that scenario I would
say no obviously so so look I would say
that there's two answers to that and we
have to use logic here right if your
husband is providing for your home and
um he's protect he's doing everything
he's supposed to do you know taking all
the boxes you cannot now say to him
after doing 15 16 hours shift at home
I'm tired come and help me like and and
doing it in an aggressive manner in the
manner where you examined him like he
like almost like you know he has to but
we're in in your second question if
you're both working then this is the
point of being a husband and wife you
both haven't had this for each other you
have that the empathy in your heart
where you both understand right teamwork
right you go do this I go do this the
quicker everything's done it's just
whatever works for your family I don't
think there's a generic answer for
everything yes whatever works for your
family but also I think we also need to
understand and start from a basic point
of you know this is a woman's this is
the women's role this is the mandrel and
then from there once you understand what
that is you then do whatever's right for
your family exactly just to mentioned
means Mercy yeah that's what it means
just yeah
so so basically um it's important and
what you said is important sister here
as well is that we are we are not
talking about these exceptions okay
we're not talking about I think anyone
in their right mind if their wife has to
work and they have to work I mean the
man has to look like there is the SWAT
meal of bless her who even though she
was working she was still doing meal
prep Etc whatever yeah okay from her
mercy the fact that she cares about her
you know ex-husband whoever might be
yeah but the point is this we're talking
about Dynamics where the man is the
provider and the woman she's at home but
she has this
um idea ideas that's been fed into of oh
are you just that um a a a housewife
just are you just a housewife oh I'm
skiing are you is that does he help in
the house these shaytans I call them
ibles yeah little iblies yeah none of
the ibizas yeah who are breaking the
household and the studies that show
women are more influenced easily
influence than men who you need is a
friend to come and say to you did you
really do that do you know things
with men I don't know if we do yeah but
again the discussion comes to let's talk
about this yeah because if for example
say like if that would be my wife I
wouldn't allow this you know but like
she's doing this
like a real man would accept that
if a man you know why you know why
because a man is logical he's not
emotional because and if you're
emotional if someone comes and says oh
my gosh my husband exactly exactly
a lot of the time when when especially
as a man if you have a friend that comes
up to you and has something to say about
you relationship as Ali said well he
can't cross that Mark yeah a lot of the
time if they have something to say if
they have a very close friend I'm
talking to a very close friend and he
feels that maybe his missus isn't
treating him right he would say well
Michael don't you know don't you find it
a bit a bit weird it's very important to
know that as a man like from your friend
telling you that it's very important
because sometimes when we do think of
our heart the person outside there is
relationship definitely sees it from a
more logical standpoint it's very
important to hear their opinion exactly
and we have another episode which we're
going to talk about should married
couple have single friends and this all
pertains to how a woman can be
influenced because we'll come to that
after but do you see the points uh
Shaquille yeah someone referred
somewhere else just from a different
angle I think we pretty much all agree
with everything that's been said because
if I remember from the last episode out
you didn't make it very that clear or
maybe maybe it was us misunderstanding
and I want to give you the hack of maybe
explaining yourself because sometimes we
say a thing and we thinking something
else and maybe it's not fairness to
that's fine I've judged you I'm glad you
said that it's not fair it's not fair
um and I didn't even though you gave me
a good little intro earlier I'm just
saying like uh the way that it went
wasn't too fair I just want to make it
clear I never once asked Ali to try and
stand up for me or any of the other
brothers or sisters that were on the
panel
um one thing I just want to make clear I
want to make it just about myself but I
feel like the way the angle the last
podcast went uh it went completely left
I'm not in no Islamic world right now
personally okay I know this much cheese
a lot of people off I said it on my life
the other day and they got people really
upset the fact that I said I don't class
myself as a practice in Muslim
let me explain myself first I know I
didn't say much on the last podcast and
there was a reason to why I didn't say
much on a lot of post podcast but let me
do things in Corona logical order okay
because a lot of weird strange things
have been said and then accusations and
just an unjust standpoint from a lot of
my fellow Muslim brothers and sisters
I'm a revert number one for me to see a
whole Muslim Community on my whole
loving brothers and Muslims that I would
literally sacrifice anything for to
literally nitpick the fact that I was
silent on a podcast for a little while
or I didn't want to speak on the podcast
about the particular topic and to go and
change it to some crazy narrative as if
I agreed with the other people that were
on the podcast it's crazy I was
disheartened and I was disappointed why
because I'm always the guy from Young
and even being a Muslim if I from what I
understood the thing that I I was
attracted to
was maybe a bit different to the theme
that is now being practiced the dean
that isil would be in practice was make
excuses for your brothers the thing that
I saw that attracted me to Islam is if
someone makes a mistake you know try to
look for the good and leave the bad but
now it's completely different it looks
like try to find the bad and any good
that he does dismiss it so that's how I
took that one
now the reason why I didn't speak on
that podcast is because there was a
podcast that was previously recorded
literally what 20 minutes or an hour
before that podcast and I accidentally
slipped up and said something and I'm
going to say it now and whoever's
offended or if it needs to get bleeped
out it can get bleeped out I said
something and I said I was given advice
to the younger men for younger men if
that were struggling
uh with finding a good woman or
struggling in relationships I was like
bro it's not always about just trying to
find the opposite sex sometimes learn to
practice semen retention now Ali kind of
not like after the podcast said she
killed try not to use words like that
and I was like okay cool I get it yeah
no problem so what happened with was
bearing in mind I was like when I said
earlier I don't class myself as a
practice of Muslim because I don't feel
like I do
the Practical things that I should be
doing as a practical Muslim I do not
believe that I am on my Dean now I know
everyone on social media really wants to
portray that they are very good practice
in Muslim may I look at the realities
from the books that I read and from the
little knowledge I have Islam I don't
class myself as a practicing Muslim I
don't say that out of boast I'm not
saying it out of
um uh you know like I'm not proud of it
I'm very shameful about it I'm just
trying to deliver some context to who I
am and why I came here now being in this
nasty disgusting unpracticing
environment okay reading between the
lines a Haram environment that I've been
in for the last four years okay I have
been making please get me out of this
nasty filthy environment and try and
provide for me a Halal alternative for
me to do something positive I know Ali
off of the camera I know him personally
he's not this social media guy like he
might be for everybody else that watches
this podcast I know his mom his mom
knows me his mom always is arcs how is
Shaquille doing because as soon as my
mother passed away Ali was there for me
more than anybody else was so me and Ali
have a relationship off of the camera so
Andy called me and said why don't you
come on this podcast maybe it can boost
what you're doing I.E the things that
you want to do for a positive change you
might be able to come here and do a
positive change I said no problem is it
going to cause me any negative you know
this whole negative toxic Muslim Tick
Tock that's gone he's like no bro it's
going to be fine I'll go in there I
didn't know who the brother was next to
me cool which is my fault no problem
actually no problem at all listen you
still didn't do anything wrong I didn't
know who the brother was next to me cool
um
the topic personally I did you and so I
see one brother that was like oh if you
knew what the podcast is about and
probably people in the room and people
watching I was like well why did you go
on a podcast then I could sometimes
sometimes
it's not always just what you think on
your side of the camera there was more
depth to what happened so the reason why
I come into the podcast number one and
he's my friend and I never told Ali no
same way he never tells me no secondly
that was the second podcast recorded
where I slipped up and said the Seaman
retention remark I said you know what
let me be even more careful about what I
say on the second film podcast which was
the one that ever the one that went
viral I kept my mouth shut for a reason
as far as I was concerned
or far as I am concerned the prophet
peace be upon him said if he haven't got
anything good to say shut your mouth so
guess what I did I shut my mouth and now
people are saying well why did you keep
quiet why did you keep quiet you can't
win but you can't win some people come
to the podcast just to talk bro I admire
the fact that he was like bro I don't
think there's anything that I can and
you was quiet but I admire that because
you're gonna come here and talk for the
sake of it too whatever it may be but
you didn't so the thing is like at the
end of the day you know people like that
said before bro they'll pick on you
they'll be consistent ability job but
I'll pick on the way I'm sitting yeah
they'll pick on your haircut yeah
they'll pick on everything so yeah
[Laughter]
they say this is not permissible I do
the same haircut oh it's not Haram
please leave me alone bro can I just add
something sorry sorry let me just make
myself clear because it's been going on
for a few weeks and it's made
it's made do you know it's not
necessarily it's because I want to just
prove that I'm right I missed the wrong
like I said I don't think I am Mr Right
in anything here
um I'm just speeding I'm free I'm
thinking about other people other
Muslims other people that were thinking
to convert to Islam and they see the
negative responses and the negative
comments underneath every single video
every single Tick Tock video the
negative sisters that wear hijab that do
negative videos on Brothers the negative
videos of brothers that got beers down
to their chest and do these toxic little
but we have to think as well about the
people that felt offended is the
continuous negative things so let me
finish my side and anyone can say what
they want after this this is the people
that I'm trying to give a bit more okay
I don't want to even come today it's
only because of those people that I know
that might be a bit confused or they
might be sincere they won't understand
what did Prophet Shaquille Romero
actually mean by this why did he come on
the podcast I'm now making it clear for
the sincere individuals out there so
anyway that's why I didn't say anything
also the fact I was sitting next to
Matthew is not a problem I'm a grown man
before I'm a Muslim I'm a grown man or
it's hand in hand I'm a grown Muslim man
if I want to come on this podcast right
now and dance like a clown I don't need
the whole Muslim communities approve
um so what I don't I prove for to say
yes brother yes you can do it I'm a
grown man if I want to dance I dance if
I want to sit on a podcast silent I can
stay silent same way if the sisters want
to stay silent they can stay silent so
you have to confront the consequences
and have some accountability and that's
what I'm dealing with now please please
I'm dealing with it right now if you
just wait you will hear me clear clear
everything copies because as I'm
clearing it up you're still saying can
you clear it up let me clear it up
if Matthew or like same way or if you're
looking
um Piers Morgan when Piers Morgan
invites people into his podcast he
invites murderers
um
he invites uh there's certain things I
don't want to say yeah pedophiles we can
go on we can go on yeah we can go does
not mean that he agrees with the island
ideologies or the mentality that the
person is who he's sitting next to Oprah
Winfrey Oprah Winfrey invites again the
same types of nasty people in society
doesn't mean that Oprah Winfrey agrees
with them clearly but within our
community people nitpick yeah but you've
got to absolutely make it clear okay the
sister I believe a mirror because I
didn't even want to watch the video back
because it was just like how could
people not see what I meant it's like
you know when you're trying to find a
thought in someone you will convince
yourself there's a thought in someone so
I believe sorry to keep painting I
believe the sister Amira said she turned
wrong to me and she goes so Shaquille
would you do the dishes my words were so
clear I said of course yeah no problem
but they don't want to steal that bro
but they wanted me and other people
maybe people in the panel as well wanted
me to go
and keep on talking about my the passion
how much passion I have about doing
dishes bro no you don't know
I have zero passion so then when the mic
was passed to me by yourself and said to
me so Shaq it doesn't mean I wouldn't
but I don't love it like if I didn't
tell my wife I would but the issue is
there was Clips going around this was
bro clips clips bro if you watch the
full pod cost I'm so sorry even though
Matthew was here yeah not everything he
said was totally wrong there was a lot
of wrong he said but there was you
didn't watch the photos look watch the
food podcast
what what the brother Matthew said yeah
and again listen I don't agree with the
I don't agree with Matthew he's a Muslim
brother so he stole my brother in Islam
I don't agree with other people maybe on
this platform today you're still my
sisters you're still my brothers I still
love you for the sake of Allah maybe
some of you said some really little
spiteful sarcastic comments on social
media which I saw and just wiped them
off cool you're still my brother my
sister I love you for the sake of Allah
what I just don't like it's just the the
it's not even about what I don't like
it's just right or wrong anyway as I was
saying the brother Mandy people were
like oh yeah but he was laughing I'm
again I'm a grown man if I want he said
some funny things there were sisters
that were on the panel but sometimes
seriously some people say you're not
serious you can't be serious bro can you
remember off but I said to him I know
what you're doing you're just utilizing
this the same way Andrew Tate did to
make to make a quick like do you think
what I was so surprised at is that
there's grown adults that have gone over
the age of puberty that I was watching
methi and was getting really triggered
by what he was saying to me maybe I'm
just good at reading the room to me I
was looking at this guy like you're just
a marketing genius yeah you're
triggering people like this but all this
all the small-minded insecure Muslims
that can't think further than their face
like we must protest against this guy
what a horrible thing come on man look
past the guy I can clearly see he's
smart and he's utilizing people's
vulnerable small-minded um weaknesses
against them and straight away everyone
got triggered look at this look at this
guy look at one sitting next to him and
you know what happened it's not even
embarrassing for him it's embarrassing
but it's embarrassing for all of the
Muslims that got triggered so quickly
and so easily look how vulnerable and
how quickly you can get triggered okay
we're talking about the one that agree
with him
I don't need the biggest concern of the
for me the biggest concern of the
podcast like the brother and he said
he's allowed to invite whoever he wants
but I will interject that when you bring
someone like that that is doing a
marketing propaganda he's coming for his
own truth he's not coming to discuss I
might learn from you I might learn
something from you my brothers even if I
disagree on some things I will agree
with you on certain things and I will
bring the respect but there is no man
there is no grown man with a right
mindset that follows Quran and sunrise
where everyone else keeps on pretending
that they follow okay that can look up
rather methy when they write mindset and
say yes absolutely right now follow him
and agree with him I do not want to know
where the salt is okay then these
brothers if there are
and he's not fair he's not
representative and it does trigger
you're doing the same thing that he does
say something why do we care so much
why are you not adult enough to control
your own self and if you don't like the
way someone is saying something you go
get the help that you need it's not my
job to sit there and think okay x y z
might be triggered if he wants to come
on a podcast and talk you know all
whatever he's saying for views that's up
to him if he you know we're adult enough
to kind of are you talking about
Humanity can I can I can I can I just go
okay guys guys once you're talking of
each other by doing a bit of buzzers you
can press it I forgot to introduce you
yeah
can I just say something can I just say
please don't Stitch me up on the on the
clip can you just do anything about me
okay so just one disclaimer yeah like uh
why do you to me it was very simple I
certain objectives number one was I
wanted I was double minded about invite
Matthew I asked box with some brothers I
spoke to myself he said bro it's going
to be really controversial I said bro
look you know I don't agree with you you
know I've done videos refuting you you
said it with your own mouth I bro the
video is a clear you know what I'm
trying to say so I said I want to
understand you better because are you as
but your wife your wife can both
upstairs and you're downstairs are you
really that evil bro I don't think so I
said sit down so he came now when I do
those clips bro I what I do is bro I put
I put the bits in so people can watch
the whole thing which people don't maybe
that's my fault but in the podcast bro
just two things mentioned number one he
came and said oh you know if I'm doing
this and then about this woman who's
plotting against her husband for 10
years and she's saved up I said bro
what's the evidence number one number
two when he talked about his wife I said
bro you're sinful you are telling me a
full context now but on your Instagram
post you were saying oh but she's giving
birth upstairs uh all the best babes and
I said it doesn't trigger sister one
second he came and he even said I heard
Matthew saying which I couldn't believe
that he would do the dishes
Matthew said on this show that he would
do the dishes are you okay all of us
agree to do bro bro did you watch that
bit no no no can I actually didn't see
that either so I came in a little bit
yeah so what I'm saying is this year
this is the problem you know what
happens they watch the first 10 minutes
yeah that's not my problem let me tell
you something Matthew said I couldn't
believe I said bro is this a new Matthew
I said so you don't mind doing the
dishes because yeah bro if she's working
and I'm working can I just say something
maybe about the brother because I
watched the whole thing I can just
finish this point please then I'm gonna
go to another the the point is this yes
that's true a lot of people say that
actually but I have something just the
host here because if there's there's
speculations yeah after clear those
because the process the prophet peace be
upon was walking with his wife and some
sahaba saw him and he had to go to them
and say this is my wife I do it yeah he
said oh mystery of Allah of course but
he said shaytan runs through the vein of
Adam so it is the duty upon the one
who's been misunderstood I have to
clarify myself it's from Sunnah so the
point is this just to finish is that
when I was doing this stuff he came over
here he will help his wife now the red
pills number two number two number two
when it came to him not helping us his
wife giving birth along he gave full
context the Midwife came my daughter was
there and I said well you're sinful for
that so watch the full podcast you know
what sorry sorry you know I have to say
yeah another man we need to oh not to
our mistakes yeah
we we made a number of mistakes number
one
um now we didn't say any mistakes
verbally but I think just for the sake
of some of our sisters that are not as
like just cause we're good at reading a
room and we couldn't take him seriously
I never thought Muslims would think so
small-mindedly I never thought that
would be so vulnerable and gullible to
believe in him but now I've seen okay
well people were can can see what
uh that it looked like we was agreeing
with him and we had we had to basically
yeah yeah and then and then that was the
last thing there were some things he was
even now let's say let's say I don't
know let's bring someone like Andrew
Tate who I just said I agree with some
of these things he says and I agree with
a lot of I disagree with a lot of the
things he says he says some things that
I disagree with completely yeah excuse
me but it's funny and I will laugh but
it doesn't I mean but my mistake was
laughing sometimes thank you because it
looks like I was agreeing with him
as Muslims you a silence can sorry thank
you okay it's the rules don't forget
what he said yeah sorry it's the rules
yeah uh one and a half minute by the way
just disclaimer I'm counting it down not
because I want to stop her because she
has the right speed one and a half
minutes for the feminine sisters yeah
because they were accusing me of
stopping the middle why would you
counting down for trying to stop her
anyway sister uh Ira you have one and a
half minutes off okay so first of all I
want to iron up because you mentioned
there was quite a few people and I was
one of them one of them we had a little
thing on Tick Tock where I questioned
you oh so it was you I thought it was a
troll account
if you had gone into the page you would
have known I'm so disappointed in your
sister okay one minute I have my reasons
so first of all it's not so much that
you weren't disagreeing with him it was
more the fact that there aren't men out
there and I know know I hear you yo I
hear you loud and clear when you say
that
for someone who follows the sun and the
Quran that they obviously shouldn't
really believe in what he said fair
enough however how many men how many
Real Men actually follow the sun in the
Quran as far as I know
it's when it comes to multiple wives the
other thing is that
people like mahedi have given men who
think like him power they've given him
they've given them a voice and whether
they are abusive men or whether they are
disrespectful or whatever formation it
may be now that they're going to go and
be like yeah well see look I'm not the
only one who thinks like that yeah and
that that was my issue right there
because it's like you may I I could tell
why he was doing I was sitting right
opposite but that's not the point the
point is that there are men who are so
sick in the head they will and they're
young they're not they're immature and
they are looking for excuse to justify
the city 25 seconds exactly and and for
you like I respect you as you said you
will die for your brothers and sisters
but then for you to laugh with him and
just to not to say actually hold on
laughing at him even yeah but how am I
supposed to know okay
and secondly it's like you're sitting
right next to him and you know both of
you I don't feel like anyone truly stood
up for the Sisters yeah but you didn't
stand up for the Sisters no no but I did
try it and you said to me on tick tock
you shouldn't have invited no no sorry
he's a lying man
you're allowed to invite anyone you want
even if they completely opposite your
views my issue here we are talking about
manipulative you know that the way he
describe
if we didn't have a person like mentally
mehdi here would we know people like
that exist it's like a learning thing
for us you're not me her brother
Shaquille didn't know that what kind of
person he was I was like that first one
I saw him on social media I was the one
of the first person recorded his life
and I was thinking what's his brother
going through like he must be having a
like a live crisis or something like
that how can you talk about single
mothers like this and that I was the
first one who pulled him up I was the
first one who had the life of him but
that guy is he's all about putting
people out there and he does have
followers we have to put him down he's a
cancer to the woman no he's a danger he
does he does have followers because the
followers
yeah he does have followers the
followers start attacking me I didn't
care because the thing is what he's
doing he's doing wrong he's he's
advising the youngsters in the wrong way
when the people are not married the
youngsters they're thinking about this
car I want to be like this guy I want to
treat my wife as a slave and all this
that this is wrong this is wrong
it's all about the manhood and the
masculinity okay defense stand up for
your sister
listen why are we rushing listen we're
not Russian we're not Russian things
that come it's because when no one's
Russians
one second number one look here
um there was a sister we've done a video
calling uh me a misogynist here okay um
I've done more for uh female Muslim
women arrogance just because she pointed
out yeah I've done more than you can
ever do in your life
can we not give certain people platforms
that they want bro exactly the point I'm
trying to make is the following okay
um is that
I like I said before I've challenged him
before hijab is done spoken to him
before I've done videos look that's done
and dusted anyone that's called in mind
won't understand that I've learned my
mistakes in the context where I think I
should have been a bit more firm but
because he's my guest I don't want to be
rude to him I'll be honest with you but
again
maybe he had the knowledge and the
ability to destroy every single thing
you were saying no no whatever that's
your responsibility brother you're the
host sister so what she brought there
was we tried we challenged them but you
need to tell me what did he bring from
the Sharia there were certain points he
made which were valid no no no no no
they can't say nothing we have to be
just are you telling me everything
Matthew said was uh no I'm not sorry I
am not interested in why he has to say
no no bring people
your attention what's your intention
with this show so I'm interested in what
he has to say and when he said something
about the protein wife he got refuted
and anything else I would say I was
saying okay there's nothing in the city
sisters and sister soul what do you mean
like for example I'm saying did they say
anything against the Sharia that we was
like oh yeah that's yeah beat your wife
up you go yes smash in the head I don't
understand what did she what did he say
in that context by the way by the way
I'm gonna give it to you by the way I
need to ask everyone please I'm going to
pray us let the show continue you guys
continue the the discussion please I'll
be back in uh five minutes because I
need to answer yeah
I give him a leadership yeah I'm a
leadership
okay I'll sit in there
don't fall off the chair okay please
please assist him okay what I want to
say is I've seen uh Brother Ali dawa
himself first of all when Mandy come out
he was done a video on him Muhammad
hijab
um put him in his place so the thing is
I personally think when he come on this
podcast I thought he might be a changed
person but with people like that
sometimes they don't change but you know
we can pray for him but that's what
makes you feel like sisters out there
will be really upset because I didn't
watch Shuffle podcast but it did sound
awful the bits that I did here I didn't
want to listen to anymore it sounded
like they were all in agreeance and I
feel like sisters will just feel like
they want whoever's on the show to show
a real equal thing and an understanding
100 honestly yeah I was at home
I'm not here to get clotted to get like
a social media following I don't care
especially in Muslim Tick Tock I can't
stand it yeah because I feel it's really
toxic okay yeah
so I didn't leave this place here
thinking oh yeah this video is going to
go viral I'm gonna get I just left like
normal didn't think it was going to go
so bad
about five six days after I saw a clip
of the podcast I said oh my God this
looks mad yeah this looks like all of us
I don't even know the other brother's
name brother if you're watching now the
ball brother yeah yeah he was like well
this is mine yeah
no of course it would listen not even it
was two of them
listen just as I must just forget it was
sitting there I felt really bad were you
there it wasn't like that yeah I don't
even know what to say and the fact that
nobody else was no no no it looked ten
times no it looked ten times that clip
made it 10 times more worse but I can
understand why the sisters were talking
about don't invite him on here because
that just created even for yourself
negative I don't mind you you're
thinking differently as long as he's
truthful he has some composure he has
respect and he's he's not coming here
and doing his property but at the same
time I think my question is why do
people get so triggered why do you value
him so much where is it no no you're not
nothing I didn't come I was invited to
come and comfort him and I refused
because I said I'm not interested it's
very very sorry it's in searching is
very very important to invite people
that you disagree with and brother said
as brother said his brother certainly
agrees with that as brother said is
you learn from your mistakes you can't
if you don't listen to anyone that
disagrees with you yeah I think the
things that he says is completely
outlandish
um
I was with my missus we were watching
the video together as we you know we
watched brother Ali's podcast and I was
watching it and I like I was laughing at
him you know as well we're laughing at
him we're not taking anything he says
seriously because the things he he's a
marketing genius it's 200. 100 we know
you are bro and we're still talking
about him now at the same at the same at
the same time at the same time the
people watching now the people watching
now can also learn from us as well we
disagree with him we can see you're all
very very respectful sisters we're
respectful they know okay these don't
know what they're talking about he he's
just saying things to get Cloud but
bottom line I'm really glad that brother
here got to clear our hits because that
it that hopefully hopefully Ali won't
cut this all out your partner he's an
idiot a certain way whereas when I was
talking passionately earliest and so
aggressive yeah aggressive
especially
I would like to go back to the beginning
um just of the just of the question of
we've you know we've gone yeah I want to
talk about that as well one one thing I
would like to say
um I'm not I don't know I'm not as old
as you guys I'm 22. so I'm very rude
that's very rude
well I would like to what I would like
to say is um I think we're all in
agreement that men if we do come home
and our wife is is having trouble and
she asked me she asked me Michael can
you you know can you please help me I'm
not gonna turn around and go no that's
your job I'll always turn around and as
a matter of fact I'm the person too go
do you know what honey don't worry about
it I'll I'll do the rest of it and I'll
finish it because that's that's my
mindset I'm a working man I'll come home
and I'll say don't worry you go to bed
I've got this the kids I'll do it don't
worry that's my personality one thing I
will say though is I think a lot of
modern day women in my opinion
especially Western women with the women
here white women my people they they
don't understand the value of being in
the kitchen I know that sounds it's very
I know it's a very harsh as a white
woman I actually agree with that I think
it's very uh it's a very what did he say
I'm so sorry it's modern women in
today's society they don't understand
the value of being in the kitchen and I
know that's a very it's a very big it's
a big statement let me register that
image that the Modern Woman do not value
I can't understand the value yeah they
don't understand the value of being in
the kitchen because they
belongs
I've been waiting to say this for a
break I've been waiting to say this the
whole party okay let's just listen to
the brother okay the one Western world
it's a very it's a very valuable place
to be because as a working man you come
home you come home to a dinner you come
home to things already done for you we
look at you and we think wow I'm working
for we value you so great much more than
the woman we come home we don't want to
argue with you one because I've been
around masculine energy all day I don't
want to come home I'm not arguing with
you and you're irritating me now I don't
even want to talk to you you're
irritating me now furthermore
that's my that's my point I do want to
say what I do want to say sorry about
that sorry what I do want to say shout
out to my nan because I live with my nan
she she she
is she's she's very older Generation
Um housewife
transition I come home traditional
housewife I come home
and everything's done for me I grew up
man and she brought me in age of five
she does everything for me I come home
hard work whether it's whether it's
carpentry out and out in the field
whatever it is doesn't matter I'll come
home everything's done for me and I
think I'll go up to bed or I'll have
dinner and I'm my clothes are ironed my
washing's all done and I think to myself
wow if I can get a woman like that I
have a Mrs thank God and I have a Missus
and she understands her value she's
recently became Muslim as well
and she watches the podcast with me
you're a great influence as well
sometimes but sometimes I make a lot of
mistakes I'll get refuted sister soul
mashallah brothers uh they did a good
job
it's one of those if it wasn't for that
I would not be
it's one of those it's one of those
things where I will go to bed and I will
think to myself what an amazing woman
what a beautiful woman she's you know
you baby brother yes
like a wedding kind of thing oh of
course of course
yeah
I I think his I think it's very
important to teach because because I
asked man and how do you know what did
what did they teach you in school the
women back then were taught how to cook
they will taught how to iron clothes
they will taught all the important
things of running a household
take it easy they're not they're not
they're not they're not tall they're not
taught the important things now neither
men or women they don't have we're not
given we're not given roles
into the world until you deal with it
and then they're forced an iPad or a
phone in their face and young kids are
being brought up with the red pill and
the complete opposite so now you've got
two extreme sizes
reaction and there's none you can meet
in the middle I remember I remember two
I remember a year ago maybe a year and a
half Andrew Tate started blowing up I
was a bit younger I must have been like
20. I was agreeing with everything he
was saying everything he was saying and
then he started to go on to the women
yeah yeah and he started talking about
the women and started talking about how
women should do this women should do
that and it's the it's an extreme it's
an extreme point of view and it's and it
and it's that's the red pill that that
people that us Brothers talk about I
think I'm not gonna lie it's polluting a
mind you need you know that's why I
listen to them to my other Muslim
Brothers
I I done a video when he then people
were on me because I called him a no
value man when he was not a Muslim when
he's not Muslim when he accepted this
time I took the video down yeah okay you
and this is what I see bro while late
and I see a lot from the system I'm so
sorry forgive me with the sisters one
lie you would there's so much stuff like
if you know me you know that sister was
calling me like a misogynist here I said
if you knew anything about me like well
and I don't do it because I don't need
nothing from you Allah I don't need
nothing from you I do it because
genuinely wrong when I comes to hijab
bro I was one of the first YouTubers who
spoke about man's hijab a man's modesty
yeah so the thing is unbalanced I never
take one side or the other but the
moment I say something about sisters all
hell breaks loose bro it's as if they're
saying you cannot say nothing to us and
let me tell you I wouldn't say it's the
mentality that they have this is
mentality there's no accountability
thank you all whatsoever they hate the
weather accountability sisters not all
not all we've got honorable sisters no
it's particularly modern world thank you
sister
we had to look guys
yeah yeah people listen to me 0.75
speeds okay you should be a yes to his
uncle honestly
I'm not a host yeah okay I did this for
a reason because I want to say some
stuff as well but I talk a lot I'm so
sorry forgive me it's good we're gonna
ten minutes can't win you talk too much
I don't talk enough right I got in
trouble for that oh anyway today's
taking a river and she's like doing the
opposite but you know what
what do you know what frustrates me do
you know no no do you know what this is
me being uh like trying to be in a just
way without really acting how I'd want
to act I want to shout scream and swear
and belittle certain people that done
certain things online I'm very
articulate when it comes to trying to
cause somebody to put someone in their
place trust me most of the men this is
me trying to discipline myself I don't
mean listen again in a negative way it's
like sometimes you've got to prove to
someone I can be a monster if you want
to go there but this is a restrained
monster that's trying to be nice and
polite about it I'm not kill about don't
push me but don't okay
why do you have to go too far no but
honestly on a decent and a bit more of
like a um a real thing when when a
sister said um oh when people got
annoyed because when you ask me the
question oh why am I not speaking I said
it's not a topic I don't see me being
passionate about this is wrong the
reason no no I never went wrong no you
didn't but this is when what went wrong
was people's misunderstanding of me I
and I understand sometimes I before like
I am easily misunderstood maybe because
of my demeanor my mannerism maybe
because of my physical appearance I
don't know but I am really easily
misunderstood what I meant was it wasn't
like it's not an issue I don't see
myself dealing with of course she's
going to do my dishes no exactly what I
understood when I was crazy I'm so happy
to hear you crazy
I'm so happy to hear it honestly no
problem just for the record this sounds
really cringe but realistically I'm like
people that I love I don't even I'm a
teddy bear I'm So Soft so when I was
seeing the Bravo like before Messi
you're still my brother by the way and I
still love you for the sake of vlogger
I'm not gonna listen I don't pick sides
I'm not like um with this group of
brothers and this because I want to get
bro I am my own individual man so I
still like you bro you're still my
brother but I just don't like a lot of
the things that you said and I know what
you're doing you say that you're not
doing it it is a marketing thing do you
bro whatever cool but my point was when
I said it doesn't seem me and a thing
being passionate about the reason why
it's because I'm thinking that my head
I'm not passionate about this you know
why dude I don't see myself with
inshallah my future feminine nice
respectful woman of the future that I
marry I go months you know get me and
her family mumps meeting who she is and
how she is as a person I don't see the
day we get married I sit down and I'm
squabbling over right you're gonna do
this and I'm gonna do this you know the
issues that I want babe where are we
going for the honeymoon yeah other
things as well
why did you not wear that dressed up why
are you not ready it's 7 P.M I booked
the restaurant why are you not ready why
are you not wearing the new shoes that I
bought you what about cooking babe what
about the earrings how did you lose the
earrings
I'm gonna have my maiden shot the one no
not my wife are you gonna marry the maid
as well let me be careful it's okay now
but on a serious level these are the
issues quote unquote I see myself
happening babe I spent so much on that
earring how comes that earrings missing
how did you lose these are the issues
not you know why have you not done the
dishes all right I'm gonna do the dishes
and you're gonna do this or I'm gonna go
and work and you're gonna Hoover up the
house this is embarrassing the other
thing as well I lost want to finish up
this last Point as well because you
raise something very important by the
way many years ago I'd done a lot of
youth work I love working with young men
specifically young men yeah why I saw a
quote one time and it was like the
person that you are now or who you're
trying to be is the person you wish you
had when you was younger and I was
thinking I've always wanted like an
older guy to perhaps give me some advice
so to the younger guys like do you get
inspired by certain people that maybe
are a bit red pill or they say some
really strange quotes understand this
and take anyone can take it however they
want most men that act in an extreme way
have since deep rooted insecurities
I don't want to because a lot of people
are Muslim I don't want to be
disrespectful okay but I mean it
honestly as I'm
and I don't want it to seem like I'm
boasting let me try and think about my
words here
I've never come across excuse me a
secure man
who gets
female attention
who gets money who gets the things that
are maybe make you a high value Man
start speaking down on a woman like
she's a piece of something on the floor
there is no secure man that does this
most of the time it's a man that has
been either neglected throughout his
whole life from women he has mommy
issues okay a lot of us can have it it's
nothing to be embarrassed about we just
need to fix them it is um is that our
revenge a lot of comments issues yeah
bro you dropped some Deep Bars thank you
and lastly yeah so my point is just to
the young men out there just because
someone might sound art I'm not as
articulate as some of these red pill
guys but just because someone might
sound so passionate and articulate and
they they make you feel like a woman
should be treated a certain way bro it's
not right it just sounds good and it
just sounds appealing a man should be a
just man and the other thing last is my
last point but I promise you've been
saying that bad times no I promise it's
a taste of your own medicine
right all right
the last thing don't make me forget my
point was such a good point oh man
go ahead
remember it what did I say what was my
last plan
when I'm hearing this stuff right
when I'm hearing I'm getting really
comfortable now yeah all right this is
how I would have been in the first place
right that's what we wanted the last
episode yeah but I got scared I got
scared right a bit more Graves now okay
guys the point is the point is
I
this whole war that we're seeing between
man against women Muslim man against
Muslim women it's embarrassing it's
really embarrassing guys we have family
like mine that are not Muslim yet yeah
that are looking at us and it's just
like how is this even a topic that's
what I meant like I don't see myself
discussing it come on this
and the other thing is I don't see
myself not being a man like you know my
wife's at home and I've come home all
day and even if I am tired I don't see
nothing embarrassing about me picking up
some dishes I'm washing it if a woman
feels like it's a bit of a feminine
trait or I'm people say are you moving
like a simp bro if I had the camera
filming me doing it I definitely don't
like a simp washing the house washing
the dishes or hoovering I feel like I
look like a real masculine man doing
that around my house you might get a
second wife again it's just insecure
people that say these things like you
know what I mean bro it's just unsecure
I'm done yeah can we can we wrap up
please no don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere just the soil uh and the
sisters please let's just wrap so the
topic was should men cook a clean uh so
please just let's wrap up from sister
soul and this way and Charlotte I just
want to thank the brother alhamdulillah
for making clear and and may Allah bless
you inshallah and make your faith easy
and strong inshallah I mean
um Mela rewards you so one of the things
I want to say just like the brothers say
like I am tired of what really shocked
me with the podcast wasn't what you said
it was upset what the brother said sorry
it was a comments and how people were
praising the brothers like people those
people are Muslims they follow Quran and
Sunnah I was very shocked but what I
want to say there is nothing like just
the brother Shakir said there was
nothing stronger than a man we all talk
about providing caring protecting you
are providing help for her when you are
there supporting her this is as well
being a man it's not your duty your
first duty is to provide and be out
there inshallah building the Umpire for
your family and that's our duty to
support you in your mission insha Allah
but we're helping each other if I can
help you with your work I'll help you
with your work if you can help me with
mine I will
um
I've I've mentioned it previously but I
feel like a man should cook and clean
and help his wife if she needs it but
she he shouldn't have to but it is up to
that specific husband and wife
everybody's different you know what
works for you and what doesn't
um I am really pleased that this whole
conversation happened today because as a
Reverb myself I have a lot of non-muslim
family and friends and I feel like
watching this podcast they will take
away so much more and such a good
outlook on Islam
um than what they would on the last one
forgive me for saying
um but I'm constantly conscious of that
so I'm I'm really pleased that
everything's just been aired here may
Allah bless you and your husband for
coming it's a pleasure they're going to
be on a few other episodes you guys
don't understand
um so just very quickly I wanted to
clear something up when I reposted some
of my Tick Tock I had so many brothers
saying yeah well you know in the Quran
it says that a woman is to be obedient
to her husband is correct but at the
same time
it's like no one's talking about
obedience there he a lot of people a lot
of men said well you know if I tell her
she needs to go and cook and clean and
she should she's going quick and clean
the point here isn't about being
obedient it's more like are you also
willing to be obedient because if she
needs your help and she asks you for
your help and you then to them and said
no because you've done a 40-hour shift
you have to answer to Allah tomorrow
and it's like out of Mercy love and
compassion that you have for her are you
not going to help her and I think a lot
of brothers also brought the sun like
that look if Prophet Muhammad
did it out of his own goodness therefore
made it a Sunnah then you know again
it's not obligatory but my question to
those Brothers is is if our Prophet
Muhammad did not do it does that mean
that you're also not going to do it now
and to the sisters who have an issue
with being obedient you know who a lot a
lot of them said yeah well it's not
obligatory upon us to cook and clean
again if you don't click and clean and
he doesn't clean then why are you
getting married don't get married as
simple as that and I think a lot of
people who are looking to get married
you need to have a serious conversation
like you're sitting on a table you need
to ask her are you okay with cooking and
cleaning and vice versa she needs to ask
him too are you okay with helping me
because exactly you can't just go into a
lifelong commitment not knowing that
you're you know if you're not even on
the same page I know Sister Aria but I I
but the thing is here it comes back to
our discussion here the fact that I have
to be look I have to be real yeah by the
way but none of me I don't need a person
no I don't I don't have the happiest
you're happy
that talks a lot the the point is here
look I understand but the discussion
here is why is there even a discussion
of the man helping in the house in two
ways number one it's a given duh hello
which you said another show yeah
I'm not stupid we're not done to go to
our wives and be like yeah I provide and
protect pick it up Danny how childish
history no no no I'm not saying you're
saying that what I'm saying is why is
there a discussion do you ever see how
does do you ever see us men no no no
yeah do you ever seen men come and say
when is the book let me imagine me
starting a discussion about brothers
well we're all married arguments here
when's the last time our wife's helped
out with our work let's start a petition
we're going to call ourselves the blue
pill guys and we're going to start a
position and say why are our wives not
helping us anymore hold on a second buff
sisters will ballistic you know what
they'll say we're at the home we're
cooking this okay Carry On Carry On okay
we're trying to make a point here we do
not ever complain about it why are we
speak like why is this discussion up
because it's feminist that's creeping
into us and I'm not saying you Society
I'm talking generally it's creeped in
where it's like yeah but why is it why
is this a discussion I have rocked my
Mercy when I come home and I see my wife
struggling I'm a human being will say I
will you know Ali devil will do the
hoovering how about you record me to the
hoovering I don't feel insecure but it's
as if our sisters are sticking on us off
no but her husband does that when's the
last time you move not just sisters
that's the bread pill red pill yes
and the reason why discussions are
happening is because of how how far away
people are from their Deans like they
only want to pick and choose what they
want to follow and not actually follow
the way it is written and that's the
problem if you follow the dean to to the
tea nobody will be having this problem
exactly and you know what Shaquille
mentioned there please forgive me my
life because I was talking about what
you mentioned about insecure well I
believe men and women who have been
traumatized by a abnormal partner are so
scarred that they think every woman is
like that that they have to have
stipulations in place of if I'm
providing and by the way I'm not talking
to anybody but if the shoe fits it's
there yeah the point is and then these
men think like or this woman think I
have to do this this and this otherwise
they're not going to listen to me you
know what that shows you marry the wrong
person that ruined and destroyed you and
you are left with those no healing right
sister soul talks about all the time
healing and accountability because you
haven't recovered you are now on fight
or flight mode where you're like no if
she needs me to do that I'm going to
tell her to do that and it turns into it
sisters as well needs to take
accountability they need to take care of
their husbands and they need to develop
those skills and be proud of it and
inshallah good women will build good men
exactly and there's nothing wrong with
the housewives there's nothing wrong
with a housewife may Allah bless every
single housewife yeah that sister SWAT
and the sisters
the beard gives it well
these muscles trust me I'm the sister
not you
[Laughter]
yeah I think the ladies have kind of
covered they've thrown you off now
haven't they they have their hooks on
like sister still right
so just like cooking and cleaning so
just like a little bit married Etc like
what you would tell me if there's this
young sister watching this yeah I would
say do whatever is whatever works for
you and your family and
do it based on the Quran and Sunnah do
not listen to feminism when I say
feminists it's even as something as
small as the music you listen to the TV
shows you watch because they're steeped
in feminism you know a lot of the TV
shows portray the man as weak and the
woman as the strong you know I'm I get
the last say so type of mentality yeah
um you've got the Beyonce's of the world
who talk about all the single ladies I'm
an independent woman but then fights by
her man when he cheats on her so they
don't show that type of you know it's
not in the media as much but the
independent single woman mindset is and
you might not be aware of it either
exactly you're not aware of it you're
for you you're just you're liking the
song you like the beat you're you know
whatever but subliminal exactly a lot of
these things we don't really see it
until it it starts to affect us so I
would say you know just be very
conscious of everything whatever we
listen to music is Haram for a reason
had on for a reason because a lot of
these cardi B's on the world and all of
these girls that we watch and listen to
and we look up to they have an agenda to
break us as women yeah so that our men
can't tell us what to do because they're
trying to you know oppress us but that's
not the truth and we are self-destroying
ourselves we have to spoke often about
the femininity masculinity everyone's
talking about toxic masculinity and no
one talks about the toxic the toxic
masculinity
no one talks about the toxic masculinity
that we women are developing this is
toxic because we are supposed to be
rooting in our femininity and like the
brother was saying we there are really
we really have to resist and fight off
the red kid the feminism or go back to
the Deans can I ask any of the sisters
on the panel here sorry Ali why do you
think so many men are toxicity
just you know
don't listen to all of these things you
know no feminism no go back to I don't
know speak to your parents your
grandparents they've got the traditional
mindset still they haven't been rooted
in this BS that we're listening to
that's right there in our hands so take
advice from them if you have to but the
two of you should know start you know if
you have to sit down with a pen and
paper and say this you know because some
people are very visual if they want to
do that let them do that but it is
between you and your husband and do
whatever works for both of you and don't
worry about it yeah
the one thing bro no no I'm so sorry
sister please
like we need better role model people
that have 20 30 years of marriages we
only see young people speaking about
marriage bring the real people the one
that I have I have 11 years they've been
married 30 years marriages people with
wisdom people
I mean I just want to say to the
brothers
um there's loads of Brothers out there
talking about high value man so what
they do if they earn money and stuff and
then they think they're high value man
for me uh this is my personal advice a
high value man is a person who looks
after his family his kids okay the thing
is the highest life in his children yeah
100 if they're happy he's got peace at
home that's a high value manner a person
who's got loads of businesses nice cars
that can be going away just like that
okay another thing I want to say to the
brothers and sisters watch your circle
who you sit down with you talk with
because there's loads of sisters out
there that sit with sisters they talk to
them and they misguide them and same
with Brothers watch your circle you know
who you sit down with you have good
people around you alhamdulillah
everything will be all right and the
home is peace okay if you go home you've
got peace and that's it that's all you
need for me personally if I've got peace
at home I don't care nothing about
anything you know what I mean I'll come
home I got peace I've got my kids there
I've got my wife there and that's it and
that's my happiest place to be bless you
guys well it was an amazing amazing
podcast especially from the last one uh
brothers and sisters probably has
benefited at home inshallah and may
Allah bless our honorable sisters who
have come here contributed on our
honorable Brothers till next time from
the bitter truth show assalamu alaikum
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now